welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
latest trailer for thor love and thunder
which finally reveals the face of the
villain gore the god butcher and flick
me he looks sick it is time for a frame
by frame breakdown of all the details
you missed and not just because this is
the second marvel trailer in one week to
lead with ass though we actually do have
to go frame by frame through that ass
shot because there are some interesting
details there not the details you think
all the details you think but also more
details than you think anyway and our
friends at short box are giving away the
first appearance of jane foster as thor
what if number 10 from 1978 stick around
to the end of this video to learn how to
enter to win let's go
kids get to pop corner let me tell you
the story of the space viking thor
odenson
he was no ordinary man
he was a god
okay we opened with this same shot of
thor meditating beneath this wisdom tree
that we saw in the last trailer but a
key difference they've now added two
figures hiking up to thor from behind it
looks like a male and a female perhaps
peter quill does look like prat's
silhouette there and then i would say
either nebula or mantis but this woman
doesn't exactly match their silhouettes
so maybe valkyrie maybe jane maybe
gamora will this movie finally reunite
variant gamora with the rest of the
guardians we can actually see that same
tree behind korg as he's regaling the
kids maybe telling the kids hey don't
bother uncle thor right now he's getting
some alone time now this blue skinned
race is actually the same tribe that the
guardians fight alongside in the other
shots i'm thinking they're the zatoan
tribe of the planet centauri 4 the same
tribe as yondu which is why the
guardians feel such a kinship with this
tribe wanting to defend yondu's home
planet so this planet is yandu's home
world of centauri 4 that would make
these other planets and stars in the sky
part of the alpha centauri system alpha
centauri being the largest sun in the
sky and it's interesting that we can see
so many of the other planets in the
horizon because it could be how this
movie visually conveys my theory that
satori's neighboring planet of centuries
6 referenced in eternals as a past
planet that the eternals helped destroy
to birth the celestial could get
referenced in this movie we might even
see the ruins of that planet in the sky
and that could be the home world of gore
the reason why he hates all gods now we
see thor powering up stormbreaker we
actually see him coming down on whoever
these raiders are in the final shot of
the trailer then thor pops the collar of
his leather vest on the benatar while
the other guardians turn to look
actually looks like he may have borrowed
some of these clothes from peter quill
like this looks like it used to be
quill's red jacket but now with the
sleeves removed because yeah there's no
way those tree trunks are going to fit
in sleeves actually the shirt he's
wearing looks like an artistic display
of the nine realms spread out across the
jacil which of course is the asgardian
world's tree and this whole tank and
jeans look looks a lot like kurt
russell's look at big trouble in little
china kurt russell of course playing
peter quill's father of the ego moving
on after saving planet earth for the
500th time thor set off on a new journey
well he got in shape
he went from dead bod
to god
okay some new shots of new asgard and
tonsburg norway and its state as a
tourist attraction now in addition to
the cruise liners one of them having the
face of volstag members of the warriors
three who died in ragnarok we can also
see a golf course now i'm not sure if
these greens are on the same field where
hella broke my near and where odin died
if so it's kind of sad for tourism to
carpet over that site but actually in
the middle of that green is some figure
that might be just a golfer with this
caddy or might be that pedestal that
contains the broken shards of mjolnir
though shards unable to be lifted and
moved and maybe now that's thor just
sitting on it thinking then thor uses
stormbreaker to change into his
asgardian leathers so if those were
beater quails closed i guess they're
gone now we can see cory reigning thor's
goats let's give this a shot tangrity
and tanyos i don't know but they
translate to teeth bearers slash teeth
snarler and then teeth grinder these
goats are famously thor's steeds from
norse mythology but like in the shot of
this from the first trailer this one
also is just framed in a weird way to
make me think that there is a third
character who has been digitally removed
from the trailer footage now i
speculated it could be beta ray bill one
of the versions of thor in the comics
and he's gotta make it into the
live-action mcu at some point so i'm
praying that's the case but behind them
now in this shot you can see more of
those blue skin sartorians so this still
would be that same planet and if that
white shot was showing gamora she would
be another surprise character that they
might want to leave out of the trailer
beta ray bill gamora someone else let me
know who you think is actually here in
the comments below then more shots of
thor's mr incredible style workout
routine battle ropes with these chains
on a giant skeleton i'm still wondering
if it could be one of the past gods that
gore has captured and tortured or once
again where's the trucker hat that
previously had mightiest avengers on it
then now he's sharpied over it that
instead of mightiest it's strongest and
then avengers is now just avenger he
crossed out the x because there's only
one of them or being the strongest
avenger a recurring joke that's been in
all these movies meanwhile his whole
look is modeled on vincent d'onofrio's
character in adventures of babysitting
where that girl thought he was thor but
another one of his fitness goals was to
toe the entire benatar the fact that
he's able to take any steps at all is
pretty impressive i feel like this
session is going to end with quill just
flooring it and yanking thor off playing
it so that they could suddenly hit the
brakes and then he like smacks up
against the back window this time
all right onto the next clip
and after all that
he reclaimed his title as the one and
only thor
oh spook too soon
jane
so thor here is fighting up these dark
monsters who are attacking the town of
new asgard these may be the black
berserkers who are gore's minions from
the comics whom he summons with his
sword really extensions of himself since
all black was a weapon of the symbiote
deity of null in the comics the black
berserkers aren't away kindred of the
symbiotes which yes remain sony
properties but marvel doesn't have to
explicitly go into the sword symbiote
backstory in this movie it is nice to
see all the other townspeople actively
fighting off the berserkers as well it's
not just the asgard protectors of the
irony are i inheriar iron jar i in her
jar i don't know but yeah we are seeing
plainclothes civilians picking up pipes
and stuff and beating them down now thor
tries to summon mjolnir but it hovers
inches from his fingers and luke
lightsabers from kylo to ray jane foster
is the mighty thor from jason aaron's
comic run in which jane uses mjolnir to
power up into thor to escape her cancer
treatments this trailer may later hint
at why jane is carrying mule here i'll
get to that in a bit right here there is
some odd editing going on because in the
reaction shot thor is suddenly now
sitted up in his brighter golden armor
in his helmet as opposed to his leather
armor that he was wearing before so
really we're seeing two moments stitch
together maybe one earlier in the battle
and then one at the end of the battle
where the two finally step up to each
other to be honest there is something
goofy about the framing here like thor
even under the mask this looks plated
into this shot as if they may be masking
something here like i'm just gonna be
surprised if this is exactly how it
looks in the theatrical version of the
movie so why the armor upgrade why are
all the characters wearing armor
upgrades i think it may be jane as the
mighty thor wielding mjolnir that causes
all the asgardians to suit up in this
new badass look like jane signals a new
changing to the guard let's move on the
old ex-girlfriend
what's a family three four years eight
years seven months and six days give or
take oh okay so jane is riding a pegasus
the same kind of steed valkyrie road in
in game she's driving into this weird
chamber see two shots of it here but
there's a wider shot later in the
trailer that gives us a big shot of it
it's filled with these golden statues
that should look familiar to you these
are all marvel cosmic entities the
clearest one to the far right is the
living tribunal this guy keeps showing
up it's the three-headed chief justice
of the multiverse its face is
representing equity necessity and
revenge they just made a cameo in
multiverse madness the first alternate
dimension that american chavez and
strange tumbled through but in that case
all three faces were separated from each
other maybe a way of showing that we
were on a different dimensional plane
there and of course another one of the
living tribunal statues showed up
severed in the void in loki at the time
i speculated could that have been a
reality where the living tribunal was
overthrown maybe by someone like gore
the god butcher the fact that the living
tribunal showing up here is interesting
but he's not alone because right behind
a living tribunal has a bald statue that
looks like the watcher uatu the
character voiced by jeffrey wright and
what if the watchers being another
cosmic entity that just oversees
observes the multiverse it's not
supposed to interfere but then if you
slide to the left there is a hooded
figure a skull presumably lady death who
in the comics thanos did all of his
dirty stuff for then on the left in the
far back there is a bald feminine figure
who looks a lot like infinity the sister
to eternity and then between them i
think that might be eon aka he who waits
an offspring of eternity who's
associated with the concept of time so
what is this place well jane entered
this through a glowing orange rift
suggesting that it's not accessible
through any physical means i'm wondering
if this could be a shrine into the
higher tier of cosmic beings above the
god tier perhaps an mcu version of those
who sit above in shadow the gods to the
gods who oversee the asgardians and land
mjolnir its power perhaps it was these
figures who selected jane to wield
mjolnir because notice it is only here
where she is channeling the lightning
and the thunder to power the hammer
these overseers of the multiverse may
have taken mercy on jane foster for her
cancer and seen some cosmic imbalance
with mjolnir being destroyed selecting
jane as the all-time keeper of thor's
heart as the rightful wielder for this
particular battle and i say this
particular because i don't know if the
plan is to ultimately have jane foster
be the permanent thor going forward that
wasn't the case ultimately in the mighty
thor comic run i think ultimately by the
end of this movie mjolnir may be
destroyed once more and like beta ray
bill may be wielding stormbreaker now
another way to interpret this is you
could connect it to the temple art of
morag back in guardians of galaxy vol 1
that art depicted four figures death
infinity eternity and entropy now we
don't know if these five in this chamber
are the only statues in this room there
could be more out of frame but either
way i think we are looking at the
reigning hierarchy of cosmic authorities
in the mcu you have humans on one tier
above them you have asgardians they
report to zeus zeus and his tear
literally being larger gods 10 feet tall
who reign over the pantheon of gods of
olympus and then all of those gods
report to this ultimate cosmic tier
including the living tribunal death uatu
eon and infinity now moving on thor says
eight years seven months and six days
since he and jane broke up now thor
ragnarok made it sound like he and
jane's breakup was recent so eight years
seven months after that would track with
this movie keeping up with the mcu
present day of 2025 but jane thinking
three to four years is not her losing
track or not caring about thor because
remember jane was blipped her face
showed up on their screens and the
official screenplay confirmed that jane
foster was one of the blip victims now
then again that screenplay also
confirmed wong dusted as well despite
spiderman no way home ignoring that
making wong's source for supreme while
strange was blipped but that would
hardly be the first mcu plot hole ever
so if jane blipped for her it would only
feel like three or four years instead of
eight and a half then chris hemsworth
makes i think my favorite vocalization
he has ever made
[Music]
and valkyrie being here confirms that
she's among thor and korg in the
guardians when they are on saturday 4. i
just love all these shots of valkyrie's
armor that bold black and silver color
with this norse logo the bold black and
silver makes her visually at least a
perfect fit for what i think will be the
final battle this movie a desaturated
one with gore and we meet him in the
next section so let's move on
the only ones who gods care about
is themselves
so this is my vow
god she will die
so we hear christian bale as gore the
godbutcher this interesting shot though
of a piece of rock floating toward a
rift in space toward a lonely planet on
the other side maybe earth maybe
someplace else on that rock surface is a
kind of cage structure it actually looks
like the red cape of thor inside of it
this might be how gore navigates from
place to place then the hilt of all
black the necker sword or whatever
they're gonna call this sword in this
movie lifts into gore's hand and then
gore reveals himself pushing out of a
snaking tangle of inky vines and
lowering his hood to show his scarred
face white robes stained with blood from
his mouth and his open wounds it seems
like we only ever see gore in black and
white except for his eyes they
especially boosted the contrast in this
shot giving it a nourish quality like we
saw in frank miller and robert rodriguez
as sin city this upped contrast just
really sharpens all the scars and the
lines of his face giving him a withered
look making him look both very strong
but also dead inside like the most
jacked corpse you've ever seen a man who
has lost everything has nothing to lose
vengeance incarnate now gore in the
comics has an interesting headpiece and
has no nose but i personally am thankful
they let christian bale keep his nose
because i don't care if voldemort is
supposed to have a snake nose in the
books i know he does it's just rape
vines look stupid in those movies they
tried to make it work it did not work
and it would have been better if they
just let ray finds keep his damn nose
christian bale has a cool scary angular
face and they are smart not to cover it
up now the vines that gore pushes
through may actually be a form of his
sword that black and white world could
actually be a pocket realm that is
created by all black now of course one
of gore's victims is falagar the
behemoth a frame taken directly by
eastside rebic's amazing artwork and
jason aaron's storyline and can we use
this opportunity to bag marvel studios
stop just giving these comics writers
and artists special thanks in the
credits of the movie pay them as much as
you're paying the directors especially
if you're lifting the frame and putting
directly in the marketing of the movie
which is directly going to lead to
advanced pre-sales blowing up for this
movie make it right pay your artists
onto the next clip
i just want to say that was very very
impressive what you did back there
[Music]
it's just my first bad guy
[Music]
you never forget your first
so thor pops stormbreaker into the goat
boat which is what i'm going to call it
now and that boat leaves a rainbow awake
as stormbreaker has the power of my
frost the rainbow bridge jane and
valkyrie help thor fight off some
olympian guards and here and actually
you can see even more clearly in that
butt shot you can see thor has some back
tattoos it looks like he inked loki's
helmet and a square shape that i think
might be mjolnir he might have inked
everything he has lost onto his back so
that might also include odin his mother
frigga jane tony stark black widow all
the things he has lost so why are they
fighting an olympus here i'm wondering
if maybe when thor showed up at falgar's
crime scene thor could have been falsely
accused for killing these gods as
olympus may think only thor has the
might to take down so many of them then
an epic shot of gore plunging his sword
clutching the blade into a planet or
moon destroying it this would explain
how he's able to kill falgar i am
wondering if gore is doing this to try
to kill a celestial that might be
gestating inside do it while you can
gore it's about to become illegal in 26
states thor tells jane you never forget
your first talking about her first bad
guy but his sly implication there is
that they were both each other's first
true loves or at least she was his and
he will never forget her on to the next
clip
[Applause]
you
are not like the other gods that kill
[Music]
because i have something worth fighting
for
so thor and valkyrie fight gore on this
broken surface that he shattered before
the photography just looks incredible it
looks as though thor and valkyrie are in
the process of being desaturated during
this fight like gore could be draining
the color and the light force from the
whole world you can see this especially
as valkyrie parries gore using one of
zeus's lightning bolts like the rest of
her body is desaturated but the color
seems to be coming from that bolt the
same is happening when thor emits a
blast from stormbreaker other than the
bolts the rest of the shot has the color
draining from it so why is valkyrie
using zeus's bolt maybe zeus has been
killed and the ranking power of olympus
has temporarily passed down to her
during this crisis it just seems like as
this final battle wages on all of the
color is going to be drained until we
are in complete black and white a
stylistic choice that we previously have
only seen in the mcu in things like
wanda vision and the first captain
america film in order to invoke a
deliberately nostalgic quality but here
looks like the color changing is a
direct consequence of factors within the
scene on to the last clip let's see who
you are and take off your disguise
and flick
oh you flick too hard damn it
should we help him eventually grape
[Music]
so russell crowe as zeus sounds like
he's committing to a greek accent good
for you russell and i gotta love the
word choice of flick which uh yeah is
becoming a bit of an mcu inside innuendo
because remember ant-man and in-game
said flick me captain as he stuck his
butt out because if you spell out flick
me in a comic sans word bubble in all
caps in italics the l and the i begin to
merge together to look like a u so you
know the line you flick too hard damn it
you get the idea and i assume thor will
not be blurred out when we see this in
theaters i love how everyone on this day
is faints aside from zeus but including
the guys and that bearded harpist
meanwhile jane valkyrie and korg wear
hooded cloaks while they sit in stands i
presume they are currently disguised not
that great of disguises but in the
officials photo that revealed bostet
they were not wearing those cloaks
seated behind them here is a god with
larger feet suggesting that many of the
gods see around them may have immense
forms ten feet tall the way towerette
and ahmet were in moon night now we
can't really see bastet too well here
maybe we'll see her better in the imax
aspect ratio version of this trailer but
you can see from her feline ears she is
turning her head a bit taking it in now
bastet and bost are both names referring
to the egyptian cat goddess but also
bost is the wakandan panther deity this
movie may suggest the mythologies of
black panther and moon knight and thor
are all linked part of the same
mythological system as moon knight
started to do by confirming the
ancestral plane is just one of many mcu
afterlifes along with the duat moon
knight maybe bost and bastet are the
same entity maybe black panther is
considered an avatar of bost and since
but shenga consumed that heart-shaped
urban met boss in 10000 bc really
wakanda mythology was the first
mythology on the planet earth in the mcu
implying that may have influenced all
the rest that is everything i found in
this trailer and we are partnering with
short box to give away a rated copy of
what if number 10 from 1978 the first
appearance of jane foster as thor it is
currently valued at over 275
and you have to imagine that number will
be going up short boxed is the easiest
and safest way to buy and sell graded
comic books you can download short box
for free on ios and android they have an
incredible selection of graded comics
everything from recent favorites to the
most valuable comics in the world all
orders are fully protected and insured
for both the buyers and the sellers
thousands of the most respected dealers
and collectors in the industry trust
short box and use it every day to enter
the giveaway visit shortbox.com new
rockstars to enter and to receive a
promo code for 10 off any short boxed
order over 100
they never do deals that good again
that's shortbox.com new rockstars now if
you live in the san francisco bay area i
am back performing improv every other
saturday night including this saturday
may 28th at 9pm within games improv in
the mission the stage works theater come
hang out with me it's gonna be fun
follow me on instagram and twitter at
eavos follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you